you welcome to this video and sorry
Gregorian I don't believe that this guy
has no title huh not now no name in them
I lost one game against them don't
remember that yeah the Queens gambit
accepted that's not like stop the
opening that are really no best usually
play something relatively team simply
because I don't know there should be
seven as a bit uncommon okay playing no
loose yeah i QP position you should try
to get in d5 and this is no exception t5
ah now one day ft 5 is already possible
while okay Bishop g5 looks normal and we
go let's go through them
that's it's already tricky business for
example if he goes before there might be
Bishop f6 Bishop f6 and g5 those kind of
things are very much in the air okay
some question is now 95 or d5
immediately 95 immediately is just wrong
why not why isn't this just good it
should be good huh I'm my life I've got
the much better development
95 Bishop g5 5555 looks very dangerous
for black yeah k just Bishop takes all
the normal moves ok now just 95 I guess
I don't see what is he doing against
that oh do I have roped you one rupee
one is sometimes pretty cute dress
resource but okay I think I Texas okay
you know it is okay anyway it's just the
question if I had something better very
shaky position for black yeah just roped
you one or who have something better I
can just drop back to f3 how does he
coordinated sighs position there cannot
move the Queen easily maybe Quincy ate
something like that there's also night
to e6 but then he then he can move the
Queen that's awkward hmm
1960s got a cream if I don't have other
night moves I think rookie one is the
simplest but i'm not sure how much of an
advantage I have I mean it is better for
white that's that's very clear but how
much is it I'm not sure so I can check
that Queen again rookie ages may be
coming okay well it's not that much it's
better but it's maybe not a super huge
advantage g-form free I said step bad
I Scott rookie age coming
anyway I win the Jeep on you might get
active I'm not sure if I can with one
minute thirty down I can play for win
okay thats that sets frankly speaking
just just very dubious to continue this
you should be very glad to have a draw
um okay Queenie five maybe I don't know
some it's really a matter of choosing
between a couple of good continuations
rookie eight maybe try to defend
actively might be an idea no no no it's
it's difficult I mean if I can clearly
see to it not much going on
draw a third okay please play that on
time jack okay cool you're very great
player mr. Gregorian draw our 3rd gen
check
now whatever check check
yeah nothing to comment comment on let's
not chat anymore it just it is see how
do we know that already check
check check check don't you don't check
you will rather lose the position or get
a lost position then consider drawing in
draw our chat and now is worse even like
four things yeah yeah that just happens
it's just a bunch of idiots sometimes
that play online but we know that
already p was worse the whole game and
was glad to get a draw really and okay
then we can just play on and win rookie
against rookie again we're two points
but possible to learn to tune to ever
lose the position yeah the question is
could have killed him because that that
opening sequences frankly right of the
dubious because it allows that led fire
break it's possible that it's really not
that much the way it's the way it went
I'm that on that particular line it's
maybe not that much it looks nice with
the rooks there on the D file but yes he
always has some kind of counter play um
chung yeah that's already just nonsense
after that he is probably worse would be
three or something but okay IRA said
okay let's let's play it play it simple
and to make a draw but okay we wanted to
check to waste both of our times and and
play that nonsense um jab not much to
say here
I wonder if I can exploit that Bishop e7
moved better because that's not very
precise maybe I should take here in this
position I was a bit quick with rookie
one it's maybe a better move because it
might just win a temple very often you
have this position with black capturing
in one go instead of two and let's this
is just an extra temple maybe he can do
it differently and try to recapture that
capture that differently it's maybe
better that's possible I don't think I
have that I mean that's all nice but
it's maybe not that much is that maybe
more more interesting the ideas to have
that night f7 idea and but probably
maybe I should take on c5 that seems
seems better anyway thanks for watching